The Quran affirms the inspiration, the
preservation, and the authority of the
Jewish and Christian scriptures. Over
and over again, like a beating drum,
Allah declares that the Torah and the
Gospel are reliable and true in their
entirety. Reading the Quran, it's as if
Allah is saying, "How can I possibly
make it any clearer to you that the
Torah and the Gospel are not, have never
been, and never will be corrupted?" And
yet our Muslim friends insist that Allah
somehow means the exact opposite of what
he repeatedly says. But we're here to
help by taking our Muslim friends
through the Quran and showing them all
the verses that their shakes and imams
have been hiding from them. Watch what
happens when we carefully read a single
Quran verse that refers to the previous
scriptures. We're going to read Surah 2
verse 85. But just to make sure we're
not taking surah 2:85 out of context,
we'll read from verse 83 to verse 86.
This passage is a response to the Jews
of Medina. It's a little confusing if
you don't know the historical
background. So, we'll read the passage,
then I'll explain what it's about, and
finally, we'll see how verse 85
completely exposes some of the lies
you've heard about the Quran's view of
the Bible. Allah says, "And remember
when we made a covenant with the
children of Israel, worship none but
God. Be virtuous toward parents,
kinsfolk, orphans, and the indigen.
Speak to people in a goodly way and
performed the prayer and give the alms."
Then you turned away, save a few of you
swerving aside. And when we made a
covenant with you, do not shed the blood
of your own and do not expel your own
from your homes. Then you ratified it,
bearing witness. And yet it is you, the
very same, who kill your own and expel a
party of you from their homes,
conspiring against them in sin and
enmity. And if they come to you as
captives, you ransom them, though their
expulsion was forbidden to you. Do you
then believe in part of the book and
disbelieve in part? And what is the
recompense of those who do so, but
disgrace in the life of this world? And
on the day of resurrection, they shall
be consigned to the most severe
punishment. And God is not heedless of
what you do. It is they who have
purchased the world at the price of the
hereafter. For them, the punishment
shall not be lightened, nor will they be
helped.
Verses 83 and 84 describe God's covenant
with the children of Israel. The most
significant parts for understanding
verse 85 are the commands. Do not shed
the blood of your own and do not expel
your own from your homes and the Quran's
claim that the Jews ratified this
covenant. In verse 85, Allah condemns
the Jews of Medina. He says, "And yet it
is you, the very same, who kill your own
and expel a party of you from their
homes, conspiring against them in sin
and enmity. And if they come to you as
captives, you ransom them, though their
expulsion was forbidden to you." So they
were commanded, "Do not shed the blood
of your own, and do not expel your own
from your homes." But they broke the
covenant by killing some of their own
and expelling some of their own from
their homes. The historical background
is that there were three Jewish tribes
and two pagan Arab tribes in Medina. The
Jewish tribes were the Bano Kanuka, the
Bano Anadir, and the Bano Koreza. The
Arab tribes were Al Khaz and Al. Two of
the Jewish tribes, the Banuku Kenuka and
the Banu Anadir, had an alliance with
the Khazra tribe. One of the Jewish
tribes, the Bano Kurza, had an alliance
with the A tribe. So, some Jews were
allies of one pagan Arab tribe and other
Jews were allies of a different pagan
Arab tribe. The two Arab tribes used to
fight each other and because their
Jewish allies would come to their aid,
Jews would be fighting on both sides of
the battle. This meant that Jews would
end up shedding the blood of their
fellow Jews and expelling their fellow
Jews from their homes. Allah had
commanded them not to do that. But if
their fellow Jews, even the ones
fighting for the opposing side, were
captured, they would ransom them and
bring them home safely because they had
been commanded to ransom their own
people. Now we can understand verse
85. And yet it is you, the very same,
who kill your own and expel a party of
you from their homes, conspiring against
them in sin and enmity. And if they come
to you as captives, you ransom them,
though their expulsion was forbidden to
you. Do you then believe in part of the
book and disbelieve in part? And what is
the recompense of those who do so, but
disgrace in the life of this world? And
on the day of resurrection, they shall
be consigned to the most severe
punishment. And God is not heedless of
what you do. The criticism here is that
on the one hand, the Jews of Medina
would ransom captive Jews because they
were commanded by God to ransom captive
Jews. But on the other hand, they would
fight their fellow Jews and expel their
fellow Jews even though they were
commanded by God not to do those things.
So they were picking and choosing which
commands to obey. And how does Allah
respond? He says, "Do you then believe
in part of the book and disbelief in
part?" He condemns them for only
believing in part of their book, the
Torah, and not believing all of it.
Allah goes on to say that if they only
believe in part of their book and not in
all of their book, he will punish them
in this world and later send them to
hell. He says, "Do you then believe in
part of the book and disbelieve in part?
And what is the recompense of those who
do so but disgrace in the life of this
world? And on the day of resurrection,
they shall be consigned to the most
severe
punishment. Why is this a problem for
our Muslim friends? Well, what does
almost every da guy or imam or shake on
the planet say about the previous
scriptures? They say the previous
scriptures have been corrupted. So, you
should only believe in the parts that
haven't been corrupted. namely the parts
that agree with
Islam. Only believe in parts of the
Torah. Don't believe in other parts
because they've been
corrupted. What does Allah say? Do you
then believe in part of the book and
disbelieve in part? And what is the
recompense of those who do so, but
disgrace in the life of this world? And
on the day of resurrection, they shall
be consigned to the most severe
punishment.
So Allah says, "If you only believe in
part of your book, I'll send you to
hell." But da guys and imams and shakes
say only believe in part of your book.
They say the exact opposite of what
Allah says in the Quran. Again, Allah
says as clearly as he says anything in
the Quran, "If you only believe in part
of your book and not in all of your
book, I'll send you to hell."
And Muslim leaders and influencers say
only believe in part of your book, not
in all of it. And who do ordinary
Muslims listen to? Do they listen to
Allah or do they listen to their leaders
and influencers who say the exact
opposite of what Allah
says? They listen to their leaders and
influencers tossing the book of Allah
behind their backs.
There are tons of verses in the Quran
that confirm the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the
previous scriptures. Most Muslims only
believe in the verses about the
inspiration of the previous scriptures.
They don't believe in the verses about
the preservation and authority of the
previous scriptures. It seems that
Muslims have been taught by their da'wah
guys and imams and shakes to only
believe in part of the Quran, not all of
it.
So I have to
ask Muslims, why do you believe in part
of your book and not all of it? You
believe in the parts of the Quran that
say what you want it to say, but not in
the parts of the Quran that confirm the
Torah and the
Gospel. What would Allah say about you
picking and choosing which parts of the
Quran to believe in?
I'm pretty sure he would say to you
precisely what he said to the Jews of
Medina. Do you then believe in part of
the book and disbelieve in part? And
what is the recompense of those who do
so, but disgrace in the life of this
world? And on the day of resurrection,
they shall be consigned to the most
severe punishment.
[Music]